I do not think I could ever date a guy
without tattoos I look at somebody
without tattoos now I'm like wow you
made it I just I feel like if I see a
guy without tattoos my brain is just
like do you not care believe in anything
they believe in themselves I think is
what's going on with somebody without
tattoos like oh I actually like who I am
well enough to not ruin it tattoos are
like an old dog you don't like that
won't die like this is just around now I
got to get used to this thing which ones
don't you like they're all stupid I like
the palm trees that was an alien landed
on a beach I love that UFO this is a
it's a grim reaper it says party
pooper and it's that's a cover up cuz I
thought the other tattoo was
dumb what was the other one it was a
clock with
wings which I got when I was 20 time get
it it was like may as well just get
popsicle stick jokes tattooed